hello reject nation we're gonna watch
today b9 another halloween episode you
know it's gonna be sexy listen if you
can leave a like that would be super
sexy also subscribe and click that
notification bell to notified when your
sexy video is up full length watch
alongs for all you sexy rejects out
there that's what we should call them
sexy rejects got a sexy reject today
check out the content we gotta offer
over there clinton full of the watch
along for brooklyn nine-nine lastly
thanks to them
physically all right
boys i probably
yeah just can't
two and a half out of five you know
maybe one day we'll call you sexy yeah
average looking
prepper
i'm walking here
let's watch the show
it's halloween
i'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume well i'm the only one who ever
dresses up no one ever gets my costume
and they make fun of me so i'm done it
really is season of the witch what the
hell charles where's your halloween
spirit but you guys always make fun of
me i have never once insulted you in my
life
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume does it matter
if i say no no
emergency costume
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but uh but yeah what
are you supposed to be a sassy car
mechanic no come on he's clearly the
rejected pop-tarts mascot harry poptart
you're making boyle football on purpose
he's elvis yes elvis stoico the canadian
figure skater no
[Laughter]
shouts out to elbow you know what this
year we should wear halloween costumes
dude a whole day of halloween themed
reactions and we won't go out we'll
livestream live streaming
candy we paid for ourselves
[Laughter]
the first year by sheer dumb luck jake
eked out a feeble victory and last year
i let the captain win because he's old
and sad sad because the competition was
so dismal is this meeting about
something about everything
this year we both attempt to steal the
same object instead of jake attempting
to steal one from me this the crown will
be locked in this briefcase which in
turn will be locked in the interrogation
room
and so on to the briefcase goes the
ground didn't sing it with me it's like
we're back in church i choose terry
all right i take charles i pick gina
gina i take rosa what that leaves me
with you let's do this hang on santiago
i'm not sure i can trust you you're
peralta's
paramour
no no no amy would do anything to win
your approval including pretending to be
in a relationship with me for the past
few weeks only to betray me now you're
not on my team amy yeah
amy's out
i found the perfect guy to set you up
with it's very sweet that you want to
set me up with someone but i do not
trust your taste in guys at all i have
spectacular taste in men you would love
nadia
you really hurt my feelings by leaving
me off your team i had no idea you felt
that way well it doesn't feel great to
be left out right totally i get it i'm
sorry captain holt
there's no camera jake i was being
serious if you're telling the truth then
i sincerely apologize
but since you're not i will defeat you
at midnight tonight we will steal his
foot fungus cream no i'm not part of
this of course not
neither am i wink
i'm sorry amy hold terry close the
blinds release the roaches alternately
he could win an illegal street race in
which my love is the prize oh my god
gina look oh
golly ew charles kill them with whatever
cologne you're wearing
operation oh crap wrong vent
oh crap
wrong vent and all because boyle marked
the wrong vent
oh my fault i thought it was the right
bet
you are mister i'm having trouble even
believing you at all right now that is
the last time
buddy
what never ever ever never ever ever
never ever will i ever never
dang you should have seen us rosa
charles and i were amazing i somehow
salted through a window cut the crown
out of a briefcase and replaced
everything in under a minute yeah i
guess you helped a little
hug
all we gotta do is guard this drawer
until midnight and the best part about
it is captain holt has absolutely no
idea he is
such a ah
you fool so we wanted jake to take the
crown sergeant are you familiar with the
hungarian fencing term hozugirich
you think he's overconfident enough i'm
the smartest man alive i'm never gonna
die
no i'm not drinking it
our foot fungus heist has gone sideways
hitchcock not now scully doesn't know
i'm in here i stole his foot cream but
then i lost it amy you're the only hope
i have of finding it you're a detective
you're a detective
[Laughter]
jake really pissed me off and i want to
help you take him down well that's an
intriguing proposition
you certainly could be useful thank you
to
jake no
why does everyone think that's where a
camera would be because the cleavage
cloaks the camera with its curves
yes sir come in nadia hey charles what
up bro
tina this was the boy i was telling you
about you're a nadia well my real name's
leo nadia is just my tag i don't love it
but when banksy gives you a nickname it
just sticks
all right this isn't a setup this is a
setup and all of this is supposed to
distract me from the heist the heist
the heist
you shut your hot lips
it's go time sergeant
no jake works so hard
i'm not saying these are from your
motorcycle but i found these stripped
handlebars outside you better not have
messed with my bike for this heist let
me remind you i'm carrying a weapon we
all have the same weapons
oh my
the scorpion has left the nest
[Laughter]
oh no
cagney lacy do you guys want to take a
picture with uncle jake yeah
that would be so fun what if we did in
the briefing room like you're assigning
them a case no
jeez is if we took a picture
right here and i could have my hand on
this cabinet okay
oh god it was in video mode sorry take
your time oh no
matter of fact what if we did one where
i had both hands on the cabinet one on
top and then one on the front looks good
yeah
all right smile no
[Music]
one
cheese
great you guys let's go find daddy
what's going on
damn witch
what are you doing nothing just uh
enjoying a taste of my favorite beverage
the soda pop
have some now
oh no why would i have the crown jake
isn't it still in the interrogation room
of course it's still in there well
i guess i'll see you at midnight hmm
after you no after you i insist
you drank a soda not sure that's the
worst thing in the world it was the
worst thing in the world
worse than a fruit forward riesling no
[Laughter]
it's the crown in a trash can wait a
minute so as to not arouse suspicion and
then retrieve it got it
hi there oh is
it they got it
look at the back screws are loose damn
it
that son of a [ __ ] is good
sir we got a problem
the crown wasn't in the trash can
amy
that son of a [ __ ] is good
i'm gonna get that crown back wait what
huh
he doesn't have the ground what is it
then i don't know who has it what do we
do pull the security tape i'll distract
them
hey look at this
[Laughter]
i'm gonna use that wait so nadia wasn't
just a distraction no 100 real i should
have trusted you mm-hmm please call him
and tell him i messed up fine but only
if you agree that your first date will
be a double date with me and genevieve
on a week-long trip to turks forget
whoa how did he do that guy has an
insane set of abs oh look he's got the
crown and he's headed to the break room
he dumped it in the trash did he go back
and get it
nope janet
yeah but which janitor amy amy janitor
who's the one person you know who's anal
enough to send out holiday cards to
every single employee
hey me
what do you want jake what i want is to
apologize to my girlfriend who i hurt
it's whom why does the word who even
exist if you're not allowed to say it
can you give me janitor al's address i
think janitor al is gonna kill the
president
ah santiago there's my protege let me
guess you want the janitor's address
what janitor
address
ow
after being excluded by both of you here
i am with the power to decide who wins
and who loses your little heist i
wouldn't have it any other way you are
my wisest detective oh
no
amy we are in love i know we've never
said it before but i think this is the
perfect time
no don't love compared to the respect of
a workplace superior amy santiago will
you back enough oh
pretending to be nice to me is worse
than being mean is it
you can both have it
charles i need your butt meet me
downstairs alpha team this is the golden
sparrow
he lives on the 16th floor i think we
beat hold here or did you i'll get the
elevator
crap looks like we're taking the stairs
all right it's 16 floors pace yourselves
forget it run as fast as you can
i win i knocked first
you're not hell
you're looking for al of course we're
looking for al you imbecile
[Laughter]
he's having a cigarette on the roof the
roof
oh my god i am the greatest athlete in
the world
no
yes sir are you al the janitor
nope i'm your worst nightmare
amy santiago oh
no
i don't understand what is happening
allow me to explain
amy and i were ahead of you though
you weren't part of this get back over
to the loser's side loser all right
worth a shot so how'd you pull it off
well it all started when i went to tell
jake how badly he hurt my feelings and
he yelled at my breasts
remember when you set off the witch
he made captain holt flinch which was
weird since his door was closed but not
weird since he actually heard it over a
bug he planted at your desk
[Music]
he left a tiny crack in the blind so i
could read the captain's lips sharon and
your kids will distract jake they'll be
here at 9 30 sharp my waffle xylophone
on the cheese man
my lip reading is not flawless
notice that slap they left open too and
i decided to humiliate you both one last
question where's the crown oh it's at
shaw's bar the official site of my
coronation
all hail the crown of death
well done
amy santiago is an amazing detective
slash genius
brings her on us nope
drinks on me nah
sorry i was acting so weird earlier hey
i don't blame you sagittarius right with
saturn where it is you're right to be
wary of new relationships
you're not really friends you know his
girlfriend through the art world yeah
plus she's my twin sister what hi leo a
kiss for my bro kiss for my boo no
a kiss for my boo
and a kiss for my sis
there
what's wrong with that
i don't know
what's the big deal
yeah you know they're not actually
brother and sister they're not related
huh twins are hot twins are
undeniably
inarguably hot there's no way that could
be creepy at all
do you know any twins i know only twins
i'm only friends with twins
you barely made the cut because you and
jaby kowai look so much alike
somebody's quick today
fueled up on
on comedy treats for halloween that name
he's a real [ __ ] huh yeah i hate her
worst character
[ __ ] yeah the way she played hitchcock
and scully like that just no longer
interfering in the men's game and won't
let the men do their thing they were
right not to trust her the whole time
you see what she did just always have to
interfere and when's man gonna have his
freedom yeah i mean yeah that's right
when can you just yell at a woman's
boobs have your freedom here here bro
huh
i want to do that even if i didn't think
there was a scavenger hunt at play you
know every time i reel out a woman's
brush they're like oh you're humiliating
me shut the [ __ ] up my eyes are appear
like proof
you know says she says you
what are you talking about what are you
talking about your eyes are right here
you're crazy
somebody's saying
you got emotional problems
you're too sensitive
[Music]
dude gaslighting people so fun
depending on how you do it depending on
how you do it yeah you guys do it right
you've got a gas light
minimal crap yeah
as few witnesses as you can
and uh and really code it into your
language you can make your heart
approving the court of law yeah
ah that was fun that was exciting that
was a really exciting one
which wasn't so predictable it was amy i
know i know that was the only odd part
was the second it was missing i was like
maybe yeah it's just about like okay so
then all we gotta figure out is they
didn't cut to her enough yeah yeah yeah
and like really make you think that it
couldn't be her because of time and
placement yeah it was the one aspect
that made me wish that this that these
episodes could be like 45 minutes or
even just a solid half hour instead of
like 22 odd minutes or a 90-minute
christmas special christmas special at
halloween yeah yes exactly yeah yeah
yeah but it's still like even despite
that it really maintained like all the
fun and joyousness and it was rewarding
when she gets to tell them off they do
throw down for these episodes
because there are so many different
like you have to really
i imagine you have to like map out your
shots so much because there are so many
shots in in these episodes and for a
show like that's network television
usually it's like you gotta keep this
[ __ ] simple when you're doing it yeah
for five days man yeah but they they
must have had to really map this out
because they did a whole lot in this one
episode there's a lot of different
sequences and it moves at such a
whiplash pace
and um
a lot of sets and bits and i thought
that the way they utilized that was
excellent they were so funny i i love
these it's like the escalation when
they're deteriorating over the course of
trying to solve this or trying to one-up
each other
but it was always so fun i mean i mean
it was funny as that was a really funny
episode that was hilarious were they
when they revealed where the mic they
didn't show where the mic was the bugger
yes it was just
happy to be
it's exactly like a jake setup that they
would do but the right amount of absurd
it's a level of comedy that's so smart
because they don't show where the bug is
earlier on you don't even question it
you're just like that's somewhere there
yeah but then to trash but then to
reveal that later it was so clever and
for him to not even notice it is even
funnier
um yeah that was a really cleverly
constructed episode and everyone got to
be involved in that one yeah yeah man
and some good costumes up at the top
some good uh you know sight gags and
scenery and things like that
the 30 seconds of nadia is
more
fleshed out than anything nick cannon
has done so far
the whole back backstory the whole
character who's interesting because he's
so good-looking and charming and it's
also weirdly knowledgeable about
everything yes yes that would peak
exactly gina's interest
it's so funny one i guess mary uh
mary lynn
ray ray cabrera rashko the 24 lady who's
genevieve i guess she's just going to be
a
recurring character now so she also has
more flesh and more backstory than nick
does all these other couples have more
character than nick cannon
dude boiling actually
they've only been in like two episodes
yeah it's pretty surprising pretty
surprising stuff but
yeah this was a this is a really special
this is really funny
had a great time with this one quality
ass episode well i like when you can
push um andre brower a little bit more
mm-hmm oh yeah he was having fun all
over this episode
yeah he's like more wacky than usual
yeah yeah yeah and like all those like
really intense deliveries and the code
names like ah so good
so funny of course we're looking for al
you embassy
yeah when he takes things very very
seriously it is comedy gold
but also like the you know uh that's a
phrase skipping over a word not skipping
over words fumbling over your words or
whereas like he's trying to lie on the
spot and flustered yeah yeah i think uh
you saw him do a lot more of that than
usual this one and i thought it was
really fun or flinching at the witch
which even the witch like you know them
moving on that was the first clue it was
like oh the witch because i did wonder
like why was the witch back there yeah
but i didn't even like that but the
second i wanted it i just
let it go right away
yeah yeah that is that was like a good
first clue that somebody's plotting
something against them
um so now next step next heist we're
going to be like noticing every single
detail get way too into decoding it
beforehand
this is surprisingly funny
but no it's not surprisingly funny it's
just it was just it was very it was just
very funny from beginning to end like
they like they had jokes that would just
surprise you like when she's reading
holt's lips
and then she starts fumbling yeah what
the interpretations are about the brain
yeah yeah yeah
and even that like like he comes in and
i was sitting there thinking oh they
left the the slat up on the thing like
that's a good script supervision like
that could have easily been fallen out
of continuity and then sure enough it's
like an actual actual plot point yeah
yeah and just like the the bit where
like we even see terry's wife again for
a hot second and and uh the only person
who didn't get any kind of payoff was
scully
oh yeah he was really left inside there
he just completely got slipped for this
episode
but yeah this was i think it's it's good
too because it's like
halloween
you know you still want that episode to
feel special so i get what you mean it's
like they're always funny and they're
always really enjoyable but this one
felt like a very like a special episodes
worth of funny
enough that it makes up for that one
predictable kind of tie-up
i mean they threw down for this one
absolutely and while it's not like
aiming for a halloween theme they're
still like halloween enough in terms of
like the witchcraft the setting the
costume bit of the the uh cold open
uh the fact that you know they're
tricking each other the whole time yeah
and then the the costume with owl at the
end like there's a there's enough there
to have it be there because like this
one really is
it's mainly they mainly honed it on the
high stone
um but it's still it still has that
halloween party this is a really funny
it was creative yeah i think that's the
word that uh i've been looking for this
whole time
learning to be more creative what's the
word
it's creative yeah
yeah yeah it's absolutely good
it is a very creative episode
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below
and uh about whatever i don't know
what's the specific thought hey do you
have do you know any twins what do you
think of twins
more than the other favorite twins
and which is your favorite of those two
twins two questions give them a call and
then leave a comment on what that call
took looks like yeah and then have them
each comment their experience and if
they get their favorite twins to then go
through the same experience we can have
this be like the most engaged video on
network marketing companies focus on
recruiting twins
they would skyrocket let me tell you
um
hey patrick
john who would be a fun person to have a
heist with dude i would love to have a
heist with gene jeter
yeah i think a heist of jean jeter would
be very fun and strange you just gave
him a video
i think so gene
let's see your heist plan buddy i want
you to pick any location or any items of
of you know some kind of value
in the city where you live and i want
you to map out how you would steal it
how you would do the heist but jean
style all right i don't want any
conventional i don't want any oceans 11
jazz i don't want like a team that you
would expect of like oh people with a
bunch of different skills that all suit
the mission what his team would be
consisting of
all models
that's right gene you have the most
picturesque heist ever recorded it'd all
be in like
lingerie or brown underwear cuddles
they could all be twitter
and they all have camera cleavage to
complete the mission oh yeah i do they
tied this back in mm-hmm and then they
would be photographing each other see it
would be like an artistic installation
but it would also be very impressive why
would they be photographing each other
it's a heist well because the cameras
are running they're not just decorative
cameras you know they gotta at least
have video of surveillance feed so that
the person gene in the chair could be
like i don't know i need one more minute
i'm just tapping into the mainframe or
whatever all right now but turn back to
her i want him
all right now you do a pose and no just
hold still just hold still while she
does the pose what's my objective today
all right wait rob the baby are we
stealing something
gene
make it real make it so gene in the in
the immoral words of star trek make it s
make it that way that i said you should
make it so
that's what they say it's right that's
what captain pike says
everyone's favorite captain
pike
[Laughter]
and and data says it too
and seven of nine and the borg says it
why do you know
because i've listened to too many
i've i've let autoplay go through when
red letter media talks about star trek
even though i have no frame of reference
there's whatever current review i've
been listening to what end and then i'll
just hear a half an hour later i'm like
oh this is a star trek video i wasn't
even paying attention but now i have
names
i was like
yeah i don't think you watch it
i aspire to watch star trek someday i
feel like i would like the one with
patrick stewart that's what everyone
tells me not picard specifically but tng
or whatever yeah the next generation
yeah mm-hmm deep space nine
no
uh ds9 is next generation seven of nine
you don't know what she's from she's uh
from the community of nine specials from
boys she's got one of the rings that the
kings of men were given by sauron all
nine of them
all right guys thanks jaden
[Music]